hello rejects I am excited to be here
today
I'm Greg Alba and this with me is John
Bailey John Bailey who you might know as
the voice of honest trailers guide as a
trailer w but yes so there's a lot of
other things as own channel epic voice
guy yeah epic you become chills for
things that they suggested the Oscars
I'm just gonna start texting you
personally like I have no control over
what I say I wanted to warm up with mr.
John Bailey today I found out he watches
The Walking Dead I actually don't know
that many people who watch it which is
weird I don't understand it's a great
watching our show what's the thing
channel called Christo for nine-nine had
a video that went viral several many
people asked me to check this out that's
been a few weeks so since it came out
but hey it's called Lego The Walking
Dead death of Glenn and Abraham spoilers
spoilers a case the internet hasn't
ruined it for you yet
you can cry yeah you're all gonna be
doing that painful pretty brutal r-rated
version of the leg of it yeah like
Leonard Tony Stark dirty girl your eyes
or six or seven for the team so take oh
damn look
are important I need you my favorite
character perfectly
I'm still alive I'm only very badly
burned
oh I don't think I caught that when I
watched the episode Wow well well done
Christo $4.99 you brought it to life
lego format it just reminds me of how
horrible that experience was a show for
both kids actually watching it pardon me
was thinking like you know they're doing
like these Lego I guess it was a thing
Chris Pratt yeah you might be cool to
have like a lego walking dad like oh no
now I want someone a walking dead
walking dead Legos yeah bricks
I feel like walking dead if they wanted
to parody themselves I feel like Lego
format would be the perfect format to
deal with it well you know I did the
Foley from what he did at Warner
Brothers Studios oh I mean they own the
Lego property just saying John Bailey
has the ideas I mean they're already
doing Lego everything why not yeah might
as well at this point and I would just
buy a little I don't know if they have
Walking Dead Legos I was totally
inspired you saw the episode like the
night of premiered right oh yeah yeah
dad I had a headache afterwards really
well I was a graphic novel fan first so
I kind of assumed that my character was
gonna go but when they threw me off of
Abraham and I was like oh no that's my
baby a rock that's what I thought it was
great because like a lot of people were
anticipating Glenn cuz of the comics so
they kill the Abraham it was like oh
it's like you doing negan impression
there's a Walking Dead Boys
although I do think agile Egon does a
great southern he does like many talks
I'm still surprised they got away with
that much violence yeah I know AMC's
basic-cable and you had a lot more
wiggle room but still it's like that was
insane
well I mean honestly the town meeting
down from the graphic novels though it
was worse every other word was
f-f-f-f-f-f-f
and they can't say the f-word no I can
get away with with [ __ ] but they can't
kick with the f-bombs
I think Geoffrey de Morgan is greatest
which is so funny to me cus Breaking Bad
they just aft and they censored it but
when it came out for Netflix and blu-ray
whatever it was uncensored I'm like why
didn't they just why this evening the
way I guess that would be so many
sensors you wouldn't even be able to
hear him talk he said how long that he
didn't like the way Bram died in the
graphic novels so you wanted to give him
a better death and how did Abraham died
in the graph I honestly don't think he
just died cuz he got bitten or eaten or
shot or something just like something
real basic throw away death and he
didn't he didn't like it everybody like
the second line that's so much better
yeah I just thought it was kind of sad
that Abraham's death got really out shot
it was it felt like they didn't cuz
usually when I have a major character go
they give them like it's like a hit by
episode and this one it was like sorry
ever ham but now Glen but we rip Glenn
you have time to mourn for - you just
gonna focus don't want to you now it was
a BOGO episode yeah totally Walking Dead
Lego format I hope this happens one day
in some kind of format even if you just
put it together just yourself i man I
don't know if I could watch an entire
episode of Walking Dead like it's kind
of a slow-moving show so watch the
slow-moving Legos my sure it's less
about zombie season I heard a theory
that the zombies are dying out yeah
everything kind of a candidate that
that's why they get more - yeah exactly
and that's why I think they're more
human focus than ever well thanks guys
for tuning in I was fun warm-up video if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today become a reject John
Bailey epic voice guy go to his channel
yeah yes a good amount of other content
on there
really funny [ __ ] it's basically boils
down to funny stuff with voices that's
that's my things as impressions and
characters like you do a lot of ones
there's some movie reviews and some
trailer reactions as well so you can go
check out that channel there's a link in
the description box probably put in the
comment box to for you guys thanks and
of course you catch his wonderful voice
on the honest trailers and screen
junkies yeah but you can also hear they
on this game trailers everyone's much
honest game fan coming very soon honest
anime trailers to screen junkies plus oh
yeah wow I didn't even know they were
doing that yeah do you ever do you're
honest which honest trailer voice for
your for your wife like when you make
love you know I added an stand-up
comedian friend one time is like find
out what what guy she thinks to the
sexiest and like do his voice when you
have sex a lot of laughter